SPEAKER 1: So the
first of those is Will.
Will, you're one of the first
uses of Dart internally, right?
WILL EKIEL: My team was, yes.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Let's talk about how he uses
Dart and Angular and Flutter
inside Google to
build real things.
WILL EKIEL: This is synergy.
SPEAKER 1: Synergy.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL EKIEL: Servers.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] Any
Germans in the audience?
One!
Oh, OK.
Three.
OK.
All right.
Thanks for hosting us.
OK.
I'm going to talk about one
of the largest and earliest
applications we've had
built in Dart at Google.
We don't really
talk a lot about it.
Because it's an
internal application,
you wouldn't be able to see
it unless you work at Google.
It's the system that
we use to power sales.
My name is Will Ekiel.
I'm an engineering
manager, and I
manage the team that builds
the UI for mobile and for web.
Any other managers
in the audience?
Any managers?
One?
Two?
Oh, yeah.
Well, I'm going to
tell you a little
about perspective of managing
a project built on Dart,
and some of the
things that might
be interesting to your
manager-- I don't know.
OK.
So let me tell you
a little background.
So if you have a product
that you need to sell,
you're probably going
to need salespeople.
And if it's a successful
product, a big company,
you're going to have a very
big team of sales people
and they're going to need some
software to stay organized.
So Google is just
like anybody else.
We use a CRM system, which is
called customer relationship
manager-- and that's what keeps
the sales organization running.
Just bear with me very quick.
The CRM system is supposed to
make the salespeople smarter,
it lets them see who
the customers are,
what they need-- let's them
understand what kind of revenue
they get, where
it's coming from.
Let's them plan jointly
with the customers.
So for example if
a customer needs
to introduce a new video
game or a new movie,
our sales people can work with
them about how to do that.
And then, it let's
them collaborate.
Because a lot of the
products are complex,
you need to sell
them in teams, so you
need to be able to
work with one another.
Now, unlike other
companies, Google
has its own CRM system--
which is the system I work on.
And why would we do that?
Well, it's really important for
us to have a very fast system.
We have a lot of data and
we need to crunch it very,
very quickly.
And we want to show a lot
of data in a very simplified
manner, very quickly
to our sales people.
So it needs to be
very, very fast.
We like to stay on
top of innovations
and be in control of
rolling things out
as quickly as possible.
We have a lot of
other systems, so we
would like it to be very deeply
integrated with everything else
that's going on.
Update real quick if
something changes.
And the other
thing is we want it
to be tailored to our values,
and the way that we sell,
and our work flows-- and want
to be in control of that.
So give you a few numbers.
This is a big
application or not?
I don't know, is it important?
That's not a number, it's
a order of magnitude.
But a lot of revenue.
I can't say how much,
but a lot of money
is managed through the system--
so it's a very important system
and it's written 100% in
Dart-- the front end at least.
[LAUGHTER]
It's been in production
for three years.
It's been serving live
production traffic, mission
critical three years ago.
As of today, we
have 30 engineers
whose only job is to
write Dart code every day.
Half a million lines of Dart
code, and about 40% of that
is shared with other
applications, such as AdSense,
that you heard
yesterday-- AdWords,
and the AngularDart widgets
that Ted talked about.
What else?
All the code is
strong mode clean.
We have 800 AngularDart
2.0 components.
AngularDart 2.0 launched
yesterday-- so no,
we did not write all
of that in 24 hours.
We've been in production
serving again,
live mission critical
production traffic
for six months with
AngularDart 2.0.
So when we launched
it, we've already
dog food-ed it
ourselves quite a bit.
All right.
This is kind of what it looks
like minus the numbers, which
are confidential.
But I can kind of show you
that it's a complex UI.
There are dozens and dozens
and dozens of views like this.
OK?
And lots of components.
And all of these little
panels are reusable widgets.
And every single thing
is an Angular component,
because we like
it to be reusable.
So there's a lot
of stuff going on.
And this whole thing needs
to build in under one second.
It has to make RPCs too, so
minus the cost of the RPCs--
so it has to be very, very
performant, which is tricky.
So 3 and 1/2 years ago,
we had this legacy system
that had reached sort of
the end of its evolution
and we had an opportunity
to start afresh.
So we looked around at a
bunch of different things--
and this was before my time.
I've been in this
project for two years,
there was another team
that was here before.
And we looked around all
the other possibilities
and Dart looked very
appealing for several reasons.
Dart could scale.
Because we knew it was
going to be a large team.
We knew it was going to
be a large application,
because the previous
application was a beast.
We knew that Dart was promised
to be very, very productive,
as we've heard here already.
Productivity was
really important,
because our build times had
gotten very slow, for example.
We wanted a language that had
good libraries to begin with,
but allowed us to build
a lot of libraries.
Because we really
wanted to be able to,
not just build one application,
but build an ecosystem
and leverage the
investment from building
one application through all
the other applications, right?
And you saw the vast amount of
code that we are able to share.
And last, but not
least it had to be
easy to learn-- because
we knew that it was going
to be a large team and it
had to be easy to join people
to the team.
Nobody knew this tech, so it
had to be easy to pick it up.
Well, there's at least one way
of finding out if all of this
is actually true in practice,
which is to try it out--
so the team did and
their initial impression
was that, yes,
everything is true.
And they launched an
entire CRM in six months,
starting from nothing.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks to Dart three years ago.
And that included
porting AngularJS to Dart
and launching Dart 1.0.
So yeah, it's very
productive evidently.
All right.
You would want to
think that when you're
done launching something,
that's your architecture
you can just move on
and stand back in awe.
But in reality, you
need to keep evolving,
you need to keep adding
a lot of functionality.
So in reality, you have people
sticking their hands there
and trying to evolve your system
without toppling it, right?
So that brought us to
one of the problems
that enough you
guys can relate to,
which is how do you scale
an application after you
have an initial
launch-- and you need
to now make it 10 times bigger.
OK.
So I'm going to tell a little
bit about some of the scaling
problems we found with Angular,
which explains why we have
Angular 2.0 today, for example.
So how many of you
guys have used Angular?
A lot?
OK, cool.
So Anger 1.0 had this
really awesome feature,
which is-- well,
Angular in itself
allows it to do data
bindings declaratively,
which saves you a ton of code--
it's very, very productive.
But we were able to do
bi-directional bindings
and we used a lot of these.
So we have two things, they
both sync to each other.
You had a third thing.
Before you know it, you
end up with one of these.
Obviously, not with three
things, you would see it.
But when you have a lot of
them, especially when you're
adding components
that you didn't write,
and that not always
run the same way,
and they make a bunch
of RPCs and so on.
So we this was one
of the problems
that we had encountered.
Angular, it's actually not
as bad as it might seem.
Angular will run through
the loop several times.
Eventually, the
model stabilizes.
You've just wasted a little
bit of CPU, but you chug along.
After a while, as
the system keeps
getting bigger and
bigger, it needs
to run more and
more of these loops.
Eventually, we were
running 10 of these
and it was still not
stabilizing, just giving
up-- so that's a problem.
Then, another version of this.
A similar problem is with
uni-directional bindings.
You have these
hierarchies, right?
Components nested
within all the way down.
Again, not with three levels.
We had 11 levels in our system.
And before you know
it, I mean, somebody
has to propagate some
state back all the way up
and that triggers another
digest and change propagation.
Same kind of problem.
For the first kind,
you solve that
by getting of
bidirectional bindings.
You need to re-architect
your app a little bit.
This one-- we came up
with this Event Bus, which
decouples it and
lets you decide when
you take the changes-- which is
a little bit if you guys have
looked at Redux, similar,
kind of directionally
in the pattern.
The other thing that
was a big deal was-- I
mean, how are you going to
build a UI in one second
when it takes you about 800
milliseconds to do in RPC?
Well, maybe you can do it
in one second on average.
If you can do a lot
of caching, you're
able to build your UI
out of cache data, right?
So has anybody ever used Streamy
or they know about Streamy,
the library?
Yes?
Well, none of my team.
OK.
So this is a library that
some folks in our team
developed, and it's open source.
You can play around with
it, it's pretty smart.
What it does, and
intermediates all your RPCs
and it catches all
the other responses.
And if you get a hit, it
gives you the cached data.
But in the background,
it's still issues the RPC
and it compares it with
what it just gave you.
And if it's different, it
gives you a newer version
of the response.
So what this means is that the
experience that the user sees,
is as they're navigating,
they see data that's
perhaps a little bit stale.
But depending on your
system, it may or may not
change that often.
And still they need to
understand what's going on
and then, maybe in
a second they see
like one cell get updated
in the table, which is fine.
Now, streamy-- that's
what gives it its name--
is that it leverages
Dart streams, which
are pretty awesome-- everybody
here is a fan of that.
You don't have to write your
code that will explicitly
check in the cache at
every single place, which
would be like very annoying.
Well, you can do it
this way or you can just
listen on the stream.
And you can either get one
value if there was a cache miss
or you can get two values
if it was a cache hit
and there was an updated value.
Or we don't do this
right now, but we
could-- is the server could
push a new value at some point
and you can get
additional values.
So we were very pleased
to have construct
like streams available to us.
So I don't know if
you saw this thing.
What's this services thing
on top of the UI components?
As the app grew,
the UI component
started to accumulate more
and more business logic.
Some of them were
making RPCs and they
had much more complicated setup
and they did too much stuff,
so it became very hard to
test them and to debug them.
So what we did is we
at some point said, OK.
Fine, let's do a big refactor.
And we moved all the code
out of the components
into just pure Dart objects.
And by moving all of this stuff
out of the component domain
and into just plain Dart
domain, tons of advantages--
one is like you can just use all
the features of the language.
Like you can use inheritance.
You can delegate certain
behaviors to Mixins.
You can have
services that manage
the lifecycle of
multiple components,
like an entire view.
You can have a view services
that cooperate with other view
services.
All sorts of stuff.
Plus all of the
stuff can be tested
later on in simple
command line VM
tests without involving
the browser-- this
saved a ton of time.
I recommend that you look
into doing things this way.
Anyway, we had a very
close partnership
with the Angular
team-- they actually
sit across the hallway from us.
And a lot of the
stuff that I just
showed you plus
many other things
are actually in AngularDart 2.0.
In the release version,
you guys can just
take advantage of a lot of stuff
that we had to go through-- you
guys don't have to.
Our testing team was
able to take advantage
of a few features of
the Dart language,
such as that are lended to do
static analysis and generating
code-- and they built us
a few very cool tools,
they're here by the
way, [INAUDIBLE].
So I don't know if you guys
write any memory leaks,
but we do.
So they built tools that are
able to find specific code
patterns that lead to
memory leaks-- kind of cool
to be able to do that.
Also, the set up of
certain test cases
can be a pain to do,
a lot of boilerplate--
it's not quite exactly always
the same tools to build that.
You saw [INAUDIBLE] talk about
page loader and page objects
in Ted's talk-- we have
generators for that.
And all these tools are going
to be made all open source
or they're already open source.
We also partner very closely
with Dan and the Dart team.
As the app started to
grow and get out of hand,
the refresh cycles started
to get very, very slow,
and so we told them.
[CHUCKLING]
And they delivered.
They made it 8 times
faster this summer.
So if you haven't used the
tools since the beginning
of the summer, they're
a lot faster now.
All right.
What else?
People in the team,
what do they tell us?
Well, we hired
some people who are
fresh out of school-- this
is one of the first languages
that they learn.
And they tell us that Dart
feels like a smaller, more
agile blank.
Any guesses?
I'll give you a hint.
It starts with J
and ends with ava.
It's very easy to learn,
very easy to pick up,
very into intuitive for people
coming fresh out of school.
Now, we have people who
have a lot of experience
with Google with
different tech stacks--
and they tell us this is a
much more productive stack
than anything else
they've worked with.
This is not like me with
a timer taking benchmarks.
But just asking people,
OK, how long would
it take you to implement
this feature with that tech
stack or this tech stack?
Pretty much I get this answer
consistently, a lot faster.
OK.
We're done.
Everything's great.
We have a productive team,
productive tech stack.
We have a great application
by the way, users love it.
Great partnerships.
We're good.
Well, there's still
time left on the clock,
so obviously you that's a psych.
So there's something missing.
Something very big
missing from all of this.
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILL EKIEL: Yes.
Yes.
You saw the slides.
OK.
So yes what about mobile?
What about mobile?
Yes, mobile.
All right.
I guess we missed mobile,
let's do mobile then.
All right.
Voila.
There it is.
See?
I just showed you
the screen shots.
We put them in there.
Yes, yes.
Done.
Mobile web.
Mobile web for the win.
So you just need to have very
small fingers to type on that.
So well, what happens
is even if you
did-- even if that made sense,
they're different workflows.
The kinds of things you would
want to do on your phone
are not the kinds
of things you want
to do at your desk-- it's
completely different things.
So it's not just that
the user experience
needs to be designed
for mobile, but just
like different features or
different interpretations
of the features.
So I don't know.
I don't know if
that's a sales person.
I know that's a model,
it's a stock photo.
I don't know if sales people on
the go look like that or not,
but we needed to find out--
so we had to go talk to them
and we did.
And we found out what they
cared about when they're on
mobile, blah, blah, blah--
and we build these apps
with numbers in the real world.
And so, you have a
bunch of visualizations.
The same thing, well, different.
The analog thing,
but for mobile.
Now, we didn't want to
compromise the user experience,
right?
We want it to feel great.
And we wanted our users
to love it, right?
So there was only
one way to do that,
which is to build a native
application-- so we did.
It has all the gestures,
everything, 60 frames
per second-- it's great.
But the problem is that--
OK, we have a web stack.
We have an Angular.
We have Android.
And well, we have users and iOS.
So all right, we get to
do it all over again.
OK.
I wasn't excited about that.
So it means I need to spin
up a whole other team.
No.
So I was like there's
got to be a better way.
And so, I talked to Flutter
team-- this was six months ago.
And I'm like, OK,
guys, can we try this?
And like, well, we're
like in pre-alpha.
There's still kind of alpha.
What we put up with some bugs?
And it was like, OK, sure.
So built a prototype, right?
Because that's one way to find
out if things actually work.
And honestly, I had
some skepticism.
Because I've work with things
that are cross-platform before
and they feel a little weird.
I mean, when you're in a
virtualized thing that lands
and abstracts the OS,
it's like it's not
going to feel like
the right thing-- it's
going to feel a little
weird to be like, you know?
I can't really
control this stuff.
So well, I don't know.
Want to see what happened?
All right.
OK.
So that happened.
That's our prototype app.
All the data is fake
and so on, but you
get an idea of what it does.
We built this
prototype on Flutter--
and it's kind of a clone
of our Android app.
What it does is, for instance,
if you're a salesperson,
you want to know how you're
trending against your targets
and so on, so this gives
you some vital stats.
Let's see.
Pacing.
Companies, who's doing well,
who's not doing so well.
You can see it's the
exact same thing.
So we built this
hierarchical table,
which is a custom component
that we had to build.
This is one of the reasons why
we had chosen to go native,
so that we could create certain
types of specific experiences
we wanted to have.
For instance, the
back little arrow
is a little bit
different on each OS.
And you know, the text is
left aligned on Android
and centered in iOS--
Flutter does all of that
automatically for you.
And look what else it does.
See?
I made this bill.
This is a bill that we
did right before I came.
And as you can see, it's
got a bug right there.
And it's the exact same
bug on both of them.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I'm excited about
that, because it means
that I get to test things once.
I mean, if we fix
it on one, it's
going to be fixed
in the other one.
And I don't think that's
a feature, so anyway.
All right.
Let's go back to our phone.
So what was our experience
working with Flutter?
Mind you, we've been working
with Flutter for six months
and it was buggy when
we started, and so on.
But the Flutter teams,
like Eric was saying,
they just kept building
the road in front of us.
And we were really
productive with it.
We were surprised how much
progress we were making.
Because ideally,
we were just going
to build some really
tiny little toy thing,
we were not even planning
on building that much.
But once we got
started, we figured out
it was like hard to stop.
It was hard to stop
building the prototype,
because it was fun--
because you didn't really
have to wait to see the results
and it was so productive.
It got to be about,
we're guessing,
about three times more
productive than working
in Android alone.
OK?
That's not even
counting what it would
have taken to build an iOS app.
We had no problem
coming up to speed.
Everything made sense.
I'm sure, you know,
it helps if you
have some mobile background.
The widget fidelity,
which was one
of the things that had driven
us to go native is incredible.
The team that that's
doing these things
is very connected with
the material design team.
They know a lot about widgets.
The shadows and all
the time little details
are very well taken care of.
And I don't know
about you, but when
I see something, a project that
makes some big bold promise
and then they actually
do that, I don't know.
I think that's noteworthy.
It doesn't happen
to me very often.
[APPLAUSE]
Sure, yeah.
And last, I mean, there's this
really interesting possibility
you now have, which
is you can share code
with your web application.
OK.
And they're not
even beta actually,
they've still got a ways to go.
So wow, I was impressed.
So given Flutter,
this is actually
the way we're thinking
about building apps.
And I think this is the way you
may want to think about them
as well, which is you
have your web application,
you have your mobile
application-- there's
going to be always a
little bit of native code
you need to write, because
they're never going
to be exactly parity, right?
But the interesting thing for
me is this layer right here.
This code is very
expensive code to write.
It's the code that has business
logic, the code that knows how
to make certain types of RPCs.
It took us a lot of
work to write that code,
is pretty non-trivial.
And when you're
building another client,
you typically have to
start from scratch.
Why?
Because it's a completely
different language.
Maybe you can read them
and then side by side,
move your Dart to
Objective C or whatever.
But that's not a fun process.
So the ability of leveraging
all of this investment
and putting it on your mobile
clients is actually huge.
And I think this
changes a lot of things.
All right.
So what am I excited about?
Well, excited about the one
that will launch of Flutter,
which we have no ETA for.
But I'm really excited
about having that.
Although, since I sit in
the building next to Eric,
we'll probably
launch before that.
I'm really excited
about all this stuff
that [INAUDIBLE] talked
about with Angular--
with faster, smaller code size.
Angular has a very exciting
roadmap ahead of them.
And frankly, I'm very excited
about the evolution of the Dart
ecosystem.
Of course, we need your
help, because well,
we need your help promoting it.
We need your help growing it.
We're making a lot more
stuff open source now,
so we're hoping
that you guys can
take it, and make it bigger, and
contribute to it-- it's yours.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]